und mit vielen anderen vor ort mein
kollege erhard scherfer er hat wir haben
gerade schon mal sprechen können über
den faktor verschwiegenheit aber
natürlich geht es für alle darum namen
zu hören nun ist das immer schwierig mit
listen die am wochenende kursieren deren
wahrheitsgehalt möglicherweise auch nur
recht begrenzt ist die frage ist gibt es
nach nachdem was man sozusagen summa
summarum taktisch zusammenfügen kann
gewisse wahrscheinlichkeiten welche
personen wir gleich auf der bühne
erleben können
also erst mal systematisch ihnen
saarland wir werden auf jeden fall die
parteivorsitzenden sehen wir werden auch
den generalsekretär sehen und natürlich
auch den kanzlerkandidaten der sich ja
maßgeblich diese ministerinnen und
minister zusammen gestellt hat er mit
ihnen muss er ja reagieren und dann
können wir als nächstes gleich mal
gucken auf die
personalspekulation der vergangenen tage
wenn nicht gar wochen und da war ja die
große frage wird karl lauterbach nun
gesundheitsminister oder nicht gibt es
inzwischen eine ganze reihe von
meldungen die sagen ja er soll es werden
und ich denke ich kann das an dieser
stelle dann auch bestätigen auch nach
meinen informationen wird karl
lauterbach gesundheitsminister in dieser
neuen ampel koalition werden dann
bleiben noch sechs posten fünf besetzt
je nachdem wie man rechnet übrig und da
ist allerdings die diskretion relativ
stark geblieben in den vergangenen tagen
und auch in den vergangenen stunden da
wissen wir noch nicht so wirklich wenn
wir da erwarten ist sind
hochinteressante posten und ministerien
wieder zu besetzen sind also auch von
daher nicht nur die personalie
lauterbach und gesundheitsministerium
interessant sondern auch in der tat die
anderen auch wenn es da in den
vergangenen tagen deutlich weniger
rätselraten und spekulationen darüber
gegeben hat und er hat wenn sie
gestatten und wenn wir die zeit haben
hinter ihnen tut sich noch nicht so viel
außer den üblichen vorbereitungen wie
man erwarten kann dann gibt es
vielleicht ein oder zwei punkte neben
olaf scholz die man neben dem was wir
uns jetzt operiert haben vielleicht auch
schon als eine echte und stabile
wahrnehmung setzen kann seit einigen
tagen ist relativ klar dass offenbar der
einer der engsten vertrauten von olaf
scholz wolfgang schmidt offenbar ihm
folgen soll ins kanzleramt als
kanzleramtsminister
übliches vorgehen sozusagen die person
des engsten vertrauens mitzuziehen oder
ja die beiden arbeiten ja schon sehr
lange zusammen und insofern wäre das in
der tat überhaupt keine überraschung
sondern man müsse es falls als
überraschung nehmen wenn es nicht so
käme dass wolfgang schmidt der nächste
kanzleramtsminister wird möglicherweise
aber darüber hat das auch die das eine
oder andere gedankenspiele gegeben
vielleicht in einer etwas anderen
position und das ganze hat dann wieder
damit zu tun dass olaf scholz ja gesagt
hat sein kabinett wäre paritätisch mit
männern und frauen besetzt wenn man sich
das anguckt ist es mathematisch gar
nicht so einfach dann also ob man jetzt
wolfgang schmidt mit serie zu der
minister riege oder guckt man sich nur
die an die dann auch tatsächlich im
bundestag vereidigt werden also das ist
alles nicht so ganz einfach wenn diese
parität stattfinden soll aber dass
wolfgang schmidt auf jeden fall eben
kanzleramt sein wird und nach wie vor
einer der engsten berater und
mitarbeiter von olaf scholz sein wird
davon können wir ganz fest ausgehen
einen weiteren namen hat es gegeben
einer nicht ganz unbekannten gerade auch
in der spd-parteizentrale in den letzten
tagen am wochenende hat sich das ein
bisschen aufgelöst der name von andrea
nahles war hier und da gehandelt worden
für einen ministerposten es gab es am
wochenende aber eine relativ sozusagen
klare äußerung von ihr dass wir sie
künftig eventuell an ganz anderer stelle
erleben können entspricht das auch ihrem
informations modus ja ja das habe ich
auch gelesen da müsste man jetzt mal
genauer nach gucken wann denn diese
position in der bundesagentur für arbeit
zu besetzen ist kann ich gerade nicht
ganz automatisch sagen ob das in
absehbarer zeit der fall ist es gibt ja
eine gewisse nähe zu dem was andrea
nahles im moment macht was die die art
und die in beschreibung der aufgabe
angeht auf der anderen seite hat die
parteien natürlich auch durchaus noch
einiges gut bei ihr wenn man sich
anguckt wie das ganze abgelaufen ist vor
zwei jahren ungefähr folgen als sie dann
nicht mehr als parteivorsitzender
zurückgetreten ist der umgang war doch
ich sage es mal ganz vorsichtig etwas
grenzwertig von dem einen oder anderen
vor allem männlichen genossen an dieser
stelle und insofern könnte man immer
argumentieren andrea canales hat als im
arbeits- und sozialministerin ja eine
sehr gute arbeit geleistet sie hat sehr
viele gesetze auf den weg gebracht und
dann auch durchs kabinett und durchs
parlament gebracht hat also wirklich
viel getan was sozialdemokratische
positionen angeht und insofern hätte sie
sich natürlich durchaus auch verdient
eine ähnliche aufgabe wie diese wieder
zu bekommen müssen wir mal sehen wie das
ganze weiter geht aber das spektrum ist
ja auch sehr groß vielleicht sollten wir
da auch noch mal gucken die spd hat
relativ viele hochinteressante und
wichtige ministerien sich verhandelt
oder herausverhandelt bei diesem
koalitionsgespräche mit den grünen und
mit der fdp wir müssen einfach nur mal
auf das tableau gucken um zu sehen wie
relevant wie auch diese position sind
aber da kriege ich ein zeichen dass sich
zum ende kommen muss werden es wird
jetzt alles aufgelöst worüber wir lange
gerätselt haben und deswegen will ich an
dieser stelle ab jetzt mal nach vorne
zur bühne
[Gelächter]
ja einen schönen guten morgen an sie
alle wir sind jetzt an einem ganz
bestimmten moment vor der bevorstehenden
regierungsbildung die in dieser woche
stattfinden soll erinnern wir uns noch
einen moment zurück am tag der
bundestagswahl ist die
sozialdemokratische partei stärkste
partei geworden und daraus haben wir die
chance gemacht eine regierung zu bilden
zusammen mit den grünen und der fdp wir
haben intensiv wochen lang verhandelt
über einen koalitionsvertrag zustande
gekommen ist und mittlerweile seine
überwältigende zustimmung bekommen hat
bei der sozialdemokratischen partei und
bei der fdp und da bin ich sicher heute
auch von den mitgliedern der grünen
bekommen wird und jetzt geht es darum
die letzten entscheidungen zu treffen
und eine der letzten runden von
entscheidungen da kommen noch ein paar
seien jetzt die bundesministerien
bundesminister zu benennen die ich den
bundespräsidenten als
sozialdemokratische ministerinnen
minister vorschlagen möchte für die
regierung die wir jetzt bilden wollen
und ich erlaube mir gleich ein paar
bemerkungen dazu zu machen die spd hat
in diesem kabinett 7 ministerinnen und
minister zu besetzen und sie damit zu
betrauen die geschicke unseres landes
voranzubringen
wir sind uns sicher dass es richtig ist
dass in dieser zusammensetzung wir vier
frauen und drei männer verschlagen
wurden das entspricht der gesellschaft
in der wir leben in der männer und
frauen jeweils die hälfte der
bevölkerung ausmachten und wo es dann
auch dazu gehören muss dass die frauen
die hälfte der macht haben und das ist
das was wir unbedingt anstreben und
deshalb bin ich sehr stolz darauf dass
es uns nun gelingt das auch zu
realisieren
wir werden das dann alles noch weiter
fortsetzen die ich angekündigt hat mit
der benennung von
parlamentarischen staatssekretären und
staatssekretären staatsminister alles
das kommt noch jetzt geht es um die
bundesministerin und bundesminister
als erstes möchte ich ihnen hier
vorschlagen eine frau die etwas ganz
besonderes werden sollen nämlich die
erste innenministerin der bundesrepublik
deutschland aus meiner sicht ist das
auch zeit dass wir eine so schwierige
aufgabe die für mit der sicherheit
unseres landes verbundenes in die hände
an der erfahren und mit dem thema
bestens bekannten frau aus deutschland
legen ich werde dazu vorschlagen dass
nancy faeser das machen soll sie kennen
sie als fraktions und landesvorsitzende
der hessischen spd aber sie sollten
wissen dass sie eine langjährige
politische laufbahn hinter sich hat und
ein ganz ganz wichtiger teil davon
immerhin zwölf jahre war sie die
innenpolitische sprecherin der
hessischen landtagsfraktion
das heißt das ist genau ihr thema das
sie niemals verlassen hat vom herzen
sowieso nicht auch als die vorsitzenden
der fraktionen im hessischen landtag
wurde und auch natürlich nicht in all
den schwierigen jahren muss darum ging
den hessischen nsu
untersuchungsausschuss zu begleiten
nancy faeser wird eine sehr sehr gute in
ministerin in deutschland und ich freue
mich dass sie mir zugesagt hat
ja ganz herzlichen dank ich freue mich
über diese ehre die menschen in unserer
republik haben zu recht den anspruch
dass wir für ihre innere sicherheit
sorgen dass kann man vor allen dingen
mit gut ausgebildeten gut ausgestatteten
personal bei den sicherheitsbehörden
insbesondere natürlich bei der
bundespolizei ein besonderes anliegen
wird mir seien die größte bedrohung die
derzeit unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung habt den
rechtsextremismus zu bekämpfen
das wird mir ein besonderes anliegen
sein und ich bedanke mich herzlich für
diese ehre
[Applaus]
als zweites möchte ich ihn fast schon
ein schlachtross 1 niedersachsen rast
vorstellen dass wir wieder in das
kabinett
berufen wollen hubertus heil als
bundesminister für arbeit und soziales
er hat wirklich eine ganz ganz
erfolgreiche bilanz in den letzten vier
jahren
vorzulegen er hat dafür gesorgt dass in
deutschland die grundrente möglich wurde
hat dafür gesorgt dass wir in bestimmten
bereichen unseres arbeitslebens schlimme
ausbeutungsverhältnisse geherrscht haben
neue verhältnisse etablieren können die
besser recht und ordnung auf dem
arbeitsmarkt entsprechen ich erinnere an
die schlimmen verhältnisse in der
fleischbranche und der fleischindustrie
oder an die wirklich schwierigen
schicksals situationen der paketboten in
deutschland wir kennen ihn als
hartnäckig und krug als jemand der sein
wort machthaber der sich genau für die
menschen und die bürgerinnen und bürger
unseres landes einsetzt um die es geht
wenn man bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales ist und auf ihn warten große
neue aufgaben die sich aus den
verständigen der kündigung der künftigen
regierungsparteien ergeben ich will nur
erinnern an die durchsetzung eines
erhöhten mindestlohns von 12 euro und
ich will nur erinnern an die wichtige
aufgabe jetzt stabile renten für die
zukunft zu sichern zwei ganz große
herzens projekte von mir aber ich bin
sicher auch von den meisten bürgern um
bürgern hubertus heil wird weiter ein
sehr guter arbeits und sozialminister
sein
wir haben eine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich bin olaf scholz meiner
sozialdemokratischen partei sehr dankbar
dass ich diese wichtige aufgabe für
unser land fortführen kann als arbeits
und sozialminister steht man in diesen
zeiten für großen herausforderungen ich
bin mir dessen sehr bewusst mir geht es
um mehr respekt und mehr
leistungsgerechtigkeit
stichwort mindestlohn tariflöhne und das
anständige arbeitsbedingungen
es geht uns als spd aber auch um einen
starken und verlässlichen sozialstaat
der als partner für die bürgerinnen und
bürger da ist er ähnlich vor der nase
sondern zur seite steht deshalb werden
wir das bürgergeld einführen und wir
werden für soziale sicherheit und
leistungsgerechtigkeit auch durch
stabile renten sorgen jetzt zudem
wichtig dass wir in diesem wandel von
wirtschaft und arbeitswelt dafür sorgen
dass die beschäftigten von heute auch
die chance haben die arbeit von morgen
zu machen deutschland muss eine
weiterbildungs republik werden und wir
wollen dass alle menschen diesem land
teilhaben können unabhängig von
geschlecht herkunft oder eben auch der
frage ob man eine beeinträchtigung hat
oder nicht wir wollen eine gesellschaft
die zusammenhält ich freue mich auf die
arbeit in dieser fortschritts koalition
und ich werde mit all dem was ich kann
vermag für sozialen fortschritt in
deutschland arbeiten in dieser regierung
herzlichen dank
sicherheit wird in dieser regierung in
den händen starker frauen liegen deshalb
will ich als
bundesminister der verteidigung
christine lambrecht vorschlagen
christine lambrecht
ist eine erfahrene politikerin eine
erfahrene ministerin die gegenwärtig
sogar zwei ressorts leitet und das ist
schon mal eine der ganz ganz großen
kompetenzen und fähigkeiten die man
verfügen über die man verfügen muss wenn
man das verteidigungsressort leiten will
das ist ein großes ressort das eine
wichtige verantwortung für unser land
und für unsere sicherheit hat die frauen
und männer in der bundeswehr haben auch
verdient dass jemand vorne an steht im
ministerium der sich für sie einsetzt er
ein herz für sie hat und dafür sorgt
dass sie gut ausgestattet werden aber
die es auch kann und das ist bei
christine lambrecht exakt der fall sie
hat in all den aufgaben die sie zuletzt
wahrgenommen hat gezeigt welche großen
fähigkeit mit wir stecken und sie wird
eine ganz ganz bedeutende
verteidigungsministerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein
[Applaus]
vielen dank für viele wird die
nominierung als verteidigungsministerin
eine überraschung sein für mich ist es
erstens ein großer vertrauensbeweis
lieber olaf scholz wofür ich mich
ausdrücklich bedanken möchte und es ist
eine herausforderung wer mich kennt und
bei olaf scholz ist das der fall der
weiß dass ich gerne große
herausforderungen auch annehmen genauso
werde ich das auch in diesem amt tun die
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
haben es verdient dass wir sie mit
anerkennung und mit respekt deswegen mit
anerkennung und respekt begegnen und ich
möchte da ausdrücklich auch die
reservisten mit einbeziehen denn die
erleben ja was die großartiges
beeindruckend das leisten wir erleben es
jetzt in der korona pandemie wir haben
sie aber auch im sommer beim hochwasser
im aartal erlebt und deswegen müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass nicht nur das ganze
ausgedrückt wird in worten sondern auch
in taten und dazu gehört beschaffung wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sie
entsprechend ausgestattet sind wir
müssen das beschaffungswesen
modernisieren wir müssen diesen beruf
attraktiv machen damit der demokratie
fest der demographie fest ist und eine
herausforderung wird sein aber die ist
ganz wichtig dass wir dafür sorgen dass
auslandseinsätze in zukunft ständig
evaluiert werden immer wieder überprüft
werden und auch einer exit-strategie
vorhanden ist wir haben gesehen beim
afghanistan-einsatz wie wichtig das ist
und dafür will ich mich einsetzen
deswegen freue ich mich auf diese große
herausforderung
ein thema ist in diesen tagen unser zwei
jahren in aller munde und ein
thema macht viele besorgt seitdem die
pandemie in der welt ausgebrochen ist
und auch unser land erreicht hat wir
sind jetzt so lange schon dabei zu
versuchen die virusinfektion in griff zu
bekommen immer wieder mit erfolgen und
immer wieder mit rückschlägen und
natürlich haben wir bei dieser
gelegenheit festgestellt wie gut es ist
dass wir ein ordentliches
gesundheitssystem haben aber wie viel
besser es wäre wenn wir ein noch viel
besseres gesundheitssystem hätten bei
dem all die schwächen und
schwierigkeiten die wir nun noch mal neu
kennengelernt haben nicht mehr da wären
und wir uns auf dieses gesundheitssystem
mit aller kraft verlassen können als
bürgen und bürger das ist glaube ich
auch ganz wichtig wenn wir daran denken
dass so viele dort arbeiten die
pflegekräfte die pflegerinnen und
pfleger die ärzte und ärzte die mit
ganzem herzen dabei sind und es auch
verdient haben dass das eine erste
priorität in der politik der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird ein
gutes gesundheitssystem mit guten
arbeitsbedingungen und gruppenangeboten
für die bürgerinnen bürger zu etablieren
und für mich ist ganz wichtig dass wir
dann natürlich auch im blick haben dass
die pandemie noch lange nicht vorbei ist
und deshalb haben sich anders kann man
das gar nicht sagen bestimmt die meisten
bürgern und bürger dieses landes
gewünscht dass der nächste
gesundheitsminister vom fach ist das
wirklich gut kann und dass er karl
lauterbach heißt er wird es
vielen dank uhr laufen ich darf mich
zunächst einmal für das vertrauen der
partei ganz herzlich bedanken uns für
diese wichtige aufgabe
ich möchte mich bedanken für die vielen
zustimmenden worte die aus der
bevölkerung bekommen habe also da ein
wichtiges amt werden wir müssen diese
pandemie bekämpfen länger dauern als
viele denken wir werden das aber
schaffen ebenso wird die zentrale rolle
spielen aber nicht nur und wir werden
darüber hinaus das gesundheitssystem
stärken olaf scholz hat eben schon
darauf hingewiesen mit unserer dass
keine leistungskürzungen im
gesundheitswesen geben ganz im gegenteil
wir werden das system wieder robuster
machen wir sind stolz auf ein gutes
gesundheitssystem wir werden es
benötigen wir werden den kampf mit der
pandemie gewinnen und für weitere
pandemien werden wir besser gerüstet
zahlen also für diese gewesen sind
vielen dank für diese zustimmung vielen
dank für das vertrauen
[Applaus]
eine der ganz ganz großen
herausforderungen dieses landes ist
dafür zu sorgen dass wir genügend und
bezahlbaren wohnraum haben das ist ein
thema das die bürgerinnen und bürger
jeden tag um treibt viele machen sich
sorgen ob sich die wohnung in der sie
jetzt wohnen noch leisten können ob sie
wenn sie umziehen müssen eine neue
bezahlbare wohnung finden ob es
überhaupt genügend gibt und ob das mit
den bedürfnissen übereinstimmt die man
hat an den orten wo man lebt und
arbeitet
das ist nicht so einfach und deshalb
haben wir uns sehr dafür eingesetzt dass
diese wichtige aufgabe wieder die
bedeutung bekommt die sie schon einmal
insbesondere den ersten jahrzehnten der
nachkriegsgeschichte deutschlands hatte
und haben dafür gerungen dass die
künftige bundesregierung wieder ein
eigenes bauministerium bekommt es geht
um viele viele wohnungen es geht um
viele geförderte wohnungen und ich
möchte vorschlagen dass klara geywitz
die nächste bundesministerin wird die
das thema bauen für sich zur aufgabe
macht sie hat die erfahrung dazu sie hat
in der kommunalpolitik in der
stadtverordnetenversammlung genau die
themen verarbeitet sie hat als landes
landtagsabgeordnete sich mit den fragen
aus der perspektive der länder
auseinander gesetzt und sie hat auch
viele erfahrungen in der führung der
sozialdemokratischen partei in
brandenburg gewonnen und ist jetzt
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende der
spd klara geywitz ist für mich eine der
ganz talentierten politikerinnen dieses
landes und deshalb will ich froh dass
sie diese schwere aufgabe
wo es um richtig was konkretes geht
anpacken will anpacken mit vielen
männern und frauen auf dem bau die dafür
sorgen dass es wieder genug wohnungen
gibt
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen der
sozialdemokratischen partei aber auch
ganz persönlich bei olaf scholz dass ich
mitglied des bundeskabinetts sein darf
ein bundeskabinett was paritätisch
besetztes ein thema für das ich seit
jahren streiten und das ist ein
wichtiges zeichen für alle frauen in
diesem land die aufgabe die vor uns
liegt es riesig 400.000 wohnungen davon
100.000 gefördert zu bauen jährlich das
ist eine herausforderung für die planung
aber auch für die bauindustrie und mit
blick auf die klimaziele müssen wir dies
auch
klimaschonend machen energiesparend das
wird auch einen beitrag dazu leisten die
ohnehin schon hohe qualität der
deutschen bauindustrie noch weiter zu
verbessern deswegen werde ich mich auch
stark machen zb für das thema thema
bauforschung denn diese forderung werden
gebraucht frauen männer junge familien
aber auch senioren auf dem land brauchen
barrierefreie wohnung und ein thema was
alle frauen im kabinett 1 das ist das
thema sicherheit die mieterinnen und
mieter im land brauchen sicherheit dass
sie nicht aus ihrer wohnung vertrieben
werden weil die mieten übermäßig steigen
sie brauchen sicherheit dass sie auch im
alter noch in ihrer wohnung leben können
und nicht ausziehen müssen weil sie
nicht mehr in den vierten stock kommen
und sie brauchen auch sicherheit dass
sie in einem stadtteil leben der sich so
gestaltet dass sie gerne weiter da
wurden wo sie seit jahrzehnten wohnen
dass es eine große herausforderung auf
die ich mich sehr freue herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung ein ganz wichtiges thema für
deutschlands verordnung in der welt wir
haben eine aufgabe nicht nur für uns
sondern auch für die übrige welt und das
wird genau in diesem ministerium
wahrgenommen wir müssen sicherstellen
dass es überall gute
entwicklungsperspektiven gibt wir müssen
hunger und armut bekämpfen aber wir
müssen auch dafür sorge tragen dass zum
beispiel nicht unsere welt bedroht wird
durch den klimawandel und die
klimaflüchtlinge die daraus erwachsenen
mögen deshalb ist das eine sehr zentrale
herausforderung und ich bin sehr froh
dass die sozialdemokratische partei die
ehre hat dieses ministerium zu besetzen
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass die
svenja schulze genau die richtige
ministerin für diese aufgabe ist sie hat
gerade zuletzt bei der klimakonferenz in
glasgow noch mal gezeigt wie sehr sie
international vernetzt ist wie sehr sie
internationales parkett beherrscht was
er eben auch zu dieser aufgabe dazu
gehört aber wie sehr sie auch globale
themen die uns dann auch hierzulande
berühren immer schon umgetrieben haben
und mit der erfahrung im rücken die sie
in ihrer bisherigen aufgabe als
umweltministerin gewandert ist sie genau
die richtige für dieses ressort ich bin
sehr dankbar dass svenja schulze nun die
dritte sozialdemokrat in dem amt der
entwicklungshilfeministerin sein wird
und ich bin sehr stolz dass es zwei mir
schutz ist
es ist mir eine große ehre im ersten
kabinett scholz den bereich der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit und der
entwicklungspolitik zu verantworten die
entwicklungspolitik hat eine lange
tradition in der spd bei dir sind solche
namen wie erhard eppler egon bahr marie
schlei und heidemarie wieczorek zeul
verbunden und ich freue mich jetzt als
sozialdemokrat in diesem bereich weiter
verantworten zu können ich habe in
deutschland mich für die transformation
für die klimaveränderung für die ganzen
veränderungen die wir vor uns haben in
den letzten jahren engagiert und jetzt
geht es um die internationale
solidarität und die globale ebene die
ich in zukunft verantworten aber das ist
eine große ehre und ich bin sehr froh
dabei sein zu können
ja dann gehört zu einer richtigen
regierung auch ein chef des
bundeskanzleramts das wird niemanden
überraschen wird wolfgang schmidt sein
und ich muss und will an dieser stelle
gerne sagen lass ich mich bedanken für
die langjährige zusammenarbeit die wir
bisher hatten und dass sich deshalb auch
weiß dass das reisegeschäft dass dort
betrieben wird auch von wolfgang schmidt
gut voran getrieben wird denn es muss ja
alles miteinander
funktionieren was die regierung all die
unterschiedlichen parteien die
unterschiedlichen ministerien
voranbringen wollen und das ist eine
gute gute unterstützung wenn das mit all
der kompetenz und erfahrung der letzten
jahre denn an dieser stelle fortgesetzt
werden kann ich bin dankbar dass er
diese aufgabe wahrnehmen will
auch ich bin natürlich dankbar ich freue
mich darauf die aufgabe des chefs
bundeskanzlerin ist es mitzuhelfen dass
die regierung gut arbeiten kann das will
ich machen mit den hier anwesenden
kolleginnen und kollegen aber natürlich
auch mit dem minister und ministerin der
grünen und der fdp
das gilt aber auch für die
zusammenarbeit mit dem deutschen
bundestag dem bundesrat und in 16
ländern wir erleben das jetzt in der
korona pandemie wie wichtig das ist und
auch darüber hinaus bei der großen
transformations- aufgabe beim ausbau von
windenergie und solar energie kommt es
darauf an dass die zusammenarbeit mit
den ländern gut klappt und ich will
dafür sorgen dass olaf scholz den rücken
frei hat da wird er das machen kann was
er versprochen hat ordentlich zu
regieren
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
ist mir eine besondere freude gewesen am
samstag dass die sozialdemokratische
partei dem koalitionsvertrag dieser
kommenden ampel zu fast 99 prozent
zugestimmt hat und heute morgen macht es
mich sehr froh in einer reihe mit
herausragenden fähigen
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
zu stehen die gerade eben vom präsidium
auch einstimmig bestätigt worden sind
wir sind also stehen als spd mit großer
freude an der seite und hinter diesen
ministerinnen und ministern und
natürlich unserem demnächst bald kanzler
olaf scholz diese sozialdemokratinnen
und sozialdemokraten werden gemeinsam
dafür sorgen dass wir endlich
wissensbasierte krisenbewältigung haben
das können wir gesundheitsversorgung
bekommen dass wir den arbeitsmarkt und
den sozialstaat bekommen die ins 21
jahrhundert passen wir werden für
bezahlbares und klimagerechtes wohnen
sorgen wir sorgen für innere und äußere
sicherheit für einen modernen staat und
wir sorgen auch für gerechte teilhabe
nachhaltige teilhabe in aller welt und
natürlich auch in deutschland das freut
mich ganz besonders heute diese minister
und ministerinnen regel auch mit
präsentieren zu dürfen als
parteivorsitzende
ja wir sind angetreten für kontinuität
und wandel wir haben große aufgaben vor
uns und kontinuität und wandel haben wir
nicht nur mit diesem koalitionsvertrag
beschrieben und mit dem was wir uns
jetzt vorgenommen haben sondern für
kontinuität und wandel steht auch dieses
künftige kabinett beziehungsweise in
diesem fall der sozialdemokratische teil
dieses kabinetts und ich bin sehr froh
über dieses team das jetzt hier auf der
bühne steht und ich hab's ja schon mal
gesagt für mich ist das ein schlusspunkt
aber was für einen schönen schlusspunkt
kann es geben wenn man gleichzeitig
sehen kann welchen anfang ist jetzt gibt
und dass heute ist der tag an dem
nikolaus groß ist und ich habe glück
gehabt dass der nikolaus nicht ganz
flüssig geworden ist ich wünsche euch
allen viel glück
dankeschön die bühne ist voll und wir
fangen an mit einigen wenigen fragen
martin grebe vom handelsblatt die erste
das mikrofon müsste da hinkommen genau
ja was handelsblatt herr scholz dass
lauterbach jetzt gesundheitsminister
wird war das also lange zeit gehackte
plan den sie hatten oder ist das ist die
entscheidung wirklich erst in den
vergangenen tagen gefallen und zweite
frage ist noch ein paar weitere posten
frau nahles soll ja angeblich pa chefin
werden auch eine nachfolge für weidmann
muss gefunden werden gibt es auch schon
entscheidungen
alle dinge werden gut vorbereitet und
werden lange vorbereitet und sie kommen
dann ans licht des tag ans tageslicht
wenn es so weit ist das ist jetzt die
riege der frauen und männer die der
künftigen bundesregierung angehören
werden die anderen entscheidungen werden
jeweils dann bekannt gemacht wenn sie
anstehen ich will das noch mal sagen
auch im hinblick auf entscheidung die
jetzt ums über institutionen gehen die
nicht unmittelbar der bundesregierung zu
gehören das wird natürlich nicht jetzt
vor der bildung der regierung
stattfinden sondern dann wenn es jeweils
auf der tagesordnung sich wiederfindet
und da sind ja auch selbst
verwaltungsstrukturen beteiligt deshalb
macht es auch keinen sinn sich zu
irgendwelchen spekulationen zu äußern
die nächste frage cerstin gammelin
süddeutsche zeitung
ja ich hätte zwei teilfragen wenn ich
davor zwar die erste sie hatten ja
gesagt es soll parität geben aber wenn
von 17 posten 8 mit frauen besetzt sind
ist das meiner meinung nach nicht die
hälfte und die zweite teil frage ist die
spd hat ihren weiß ich ja auch sehr
fehlen direktmandaten im osten in den
fünf neuen bundesländern zu verdanken
wenn ich ihr kabinett anschaue da ist
dann eine frau aus dem osten dabei ist
das nicht angehe ist das angemessen aus
ihrer sicht der schönen dank für die
frage in der tat die parität ist mir
wichtig deshalb werden von 16
ministerium minister nacht männer und
acht frauen seien und selbstverständlich
wird es dann noch ein bundeskanzler
geben der für alle gemeinsam zuständig
ist und sich für diese fragen einsetzt
ich glaube dass es auch gut ist dass die
sozialdemokratische partei sich
entschlossen hat vier ministerinnen und
drei minister in das kann nett zu
entsenden und das ist glaube ich auch
ein zeichen dafür dass das tief
verankert ist und das nicht nur von mir
so gesehen wird sondern von allen und
besonders stolz bin ich darauf dass
gerade so
ressorts bei denen das keineswegs in der
tradition liegt jetzt von frauen geführt
werden ich mache das noch mal hier klar
da stehen sie die
künftige innenminister die künftige
verteidigungsminister und die künftige
ministerin aus meiner sicht ein ganz
ganz bemerkenswertes zeichen und
vielleicht auch das noch ist es gut dass
wir eine große
vertretung all der unterschiedlichen
bereiche unseres landes in dem kabinett
wiederfinden und das mit klarer geist
eine ostdeutsche ministerin wird das ist
auch etwas ganz ganz bedeutendes
übrigens auch im hinblick auf dieses
ganz konkrete ressort das will ich
ausdrücklich dazu sagen und wie schon
angekündigt werden wer dann die weiteren
entscheidungen treffen im hinblick zum
beispiel auf die parlamentarischen
staatssekretäre staatssekretär und die
staatsministerin staatsminister und auch
das wird noch mal eine weitere
gelegenheit sein klar zu machen wie wir
genau zu denen dingen stehen die bevor
er gesagt haben wir setzen sie nämlich
um
die nächste frage tim braune
herr scholz am donnerstag findet eine
erneute ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zur
pandemie statt
sehen sie noch bedarf für
nachbesserungen für feintuning gegenüber
dem vorangegangenen beschluss und noch
eine frage zur lage in ostdeutschland
dort haben viele leute die bilder
entsetzt als einen fackel tragen da mob
vor das haus von frau kipping gezogen
ist besorgt sie diese lage und
vereinigen auch vor dem hintergrund der
diskussion um die einführung einer
allgemeinen pflicht
zunächst einmal will ich auf die letzte
frage eingehen die sehen dort gestellt
haben aus meiner sicht ist das ganz
furchtbar was wir dafür bilder gesehen
haben und noch viel furchtbarer ist da
was passiert ist und es dürfen wir uns
als land nicht gefallen lassen ich finde
dass es die ganz klare botschaft die von
uns allen ausgehen muss als
demokratinnen und demokraten und deshalb
bin ich sehr sehr sicher dass ich da
nicht alleine stehe und auch nicht die
sozialdemokratische partei so viele
andere das entschieden zurückweisen
werden für mich ist es so dass wir auch
niemanden damit durchkommen lassen
dürfen dass er irgendwie
vergrätzt ist und deshalb solche dinge
tun darf in der welt in der wir leben
gibt es viele sachen die wir
unterschiedliche meinungen haben können
und ihn müssen und dürfen wir
diskutieren und natürlich ist es auch
erlebt erlaubt
engagiert zu diskutieren aber dass das
ist als bedrohung gemeint und das
sollten wir sollten nicht so tun als ob
es nicht auch genau das gewesen ist eine
bedrohung an der demokratischen
fleißigen und ganz tollen politikerinnen
in sachsen und das ist unser geschäft
als alle demokrat und demokraten dass
wir das zurückweisen
ansonsten gilt für die pandemie dass es
niemals den punkt gibt wo man alles
getan hat und deshalb werden wir bei all
den beratungen die wir demnächst haben
immer diese frage neu wegen muss noch
etwas gemacht werden denn froh über die
dramatischen fortschritte die wir letzte
woche erzielt haben die jetzt ja genau
in den gesetzgebungsprozess einbinden
und mütze nicht steht da hinten der
fraktionsvorsitzende der
sozialdemokratischen partei und er
kämpft gerade sehr sehr engagiert dafür
dass das auch ein sehr schnelles
gesetzgebungsverfahren wird damit die
instrumente über die wir dort geredet
haben auch allen rechtzeitig zur
verfügung stehen ich würde ja gerne zu
mehr parität auch bei den fragen
aufwerfe aufrufen jetzt aber erstmal
gordon repinski mit der vorletzten frage
ja herr scholz und frau feser zwei kurze
fragen feser sie sind für viele
überraschende personalie weil man sie
eigentlich auf dem schirm hatte als
spitzenkandidatin für die hessische
landtagswahl in zwei jahren wird die
frage gelöst haben sich darüber schon
gedanken gemacht und herr scholz
vielleicht noch eine frau carsten
schneider hatte die unterstützung der
ostdeutschen landesverbände viele haben
ihn im kabinett gesehen das ist ja jetzt
nicht wo sehen sie carsten schneider
fragen vielleicht darf ich da kurz zu
beiden auch was sagen es ist klar hier
wird ein kabinettsposten besetzt um den
geht es jetzt um der wird wahrgenommen
das ist eine sache die man mit langer
perspektive vorantreiben muss und alle
anderen fragen werden in hessen
entschieden wenn sie soweit sind ich
glaube das ist das was sich berichten
kann auch aus unseren gesprächen und
ansonsten habe ich ja schon gesagt dass
wir alle als sozialdemokratische partei
unsere große aufgabe sehen in der
regierung in der fraktion aber natürlich
auch im hinblick auf all die weiteren
aufgaben die noch konkret von uns
wahrgenommen werden müssen das ist ja
jetzt ein ganz ganz intensives geschäft
nicht so wie usa wo tausende stellen in
einem transition prozesse neu besetzt
werden aber es sind schon eine ganze
menge und mein persönliches credo ist
das sehr sehr gut zu machen und da kann
ich ihnen sagen dass ich das im tiefsten
einvernehmen mache auch mit carsten
schneider und auch mit dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden der
sozialdemokratischen partei weil die
sind ganz ganz wichtig dafür dass uns
diese sache in den nächsten jahren
gelingt und das werden sie auch merken
bei all dem was wir noch zu entscheiden
haben
herr lauterbach ich meine frage an sie
ein ganz besonderes augenmerk wird jetzt
darauf liegen welche akzente sie als
neuer bundesgesundheitsminister in der
pandemie bekämpfung setzen wollen können
sie uns das mal ein bisschen ihre
gedanken mitteilen und was glauben sie
welche rolle kohle für unser
weihnachtsfest spiel wird
frage die es zu direkt an karl
lauterbach gerichtet dass ich sie nicht
einfach beantworten will aber wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass wir ein bisschen
jetzt den anstand waren aus unserer
sicht jedenfalls und am mittwoch wird
eine regierung gebildet und dann stehen
in diese frauen und männer als
ministerinnen und minister zur verfügung
aber ich denke mal zwei sätze zum heran
klar ist laut sein was im vordergrund
jetzt natürlich stehen muss dass wir in
den wochen die wir noch haben die
fallzahlen so stark absenken dass wir
möglichst gute weihnachtsferien feiern
können und auch reisen können aber so
ein wichtiges ziel muss sein die
fallzahlen so stark herunter zu bringen
dass wir ohne die menschen zu gefährden
reisen empfehlen können darf wenn der
wert legen großen wert legen
schönen dank für ihr interesse und sie
werden diese frauen und männer noch
öfter sehen und in allen details kennen
lernen sie werden finden es sind sehr
gute frauen und männer
[Applaus]
die spd mitglieder des neuen ampel
kabinetts gehen sie hin begleitet von
der spitze von partei und fraktion es
hat die eine oder andere überraschung
gegeben das ist ihm nicht verborgen
geblieben nancy faeser hatte hier keiner
so wirklich auf dem schirm klara geywitz
dafür gab es eine kleine
wahrscheinlichkeit ganz sicherlich dass
christine lambrecht auch wieder
ministerin sein könnte haben auch viele
vermutet dass es unbedingt verteidigung
sein würde haben dann wiederum weniger
vermutet aber jetzt sind alle namen da
und die größte spekulation demjenigen
oder sagen wir mal das ministerium dass
es das größte rätselraten gegeben hat
und auch die stärksten forderungen aus
der öffentlichkeit nach karl lauterbach
sie können jetzt zufrieden sein
jedenfalls alle die die sich karl
lauterbach gewünscht haben seine
expertise auf diesem gebiet steht außer
frage und insofern dürften viele
tatsächlich jetzt zufrieden sein die ihn
unbedingt haben wollten dass karl
lauterbach nun auch tatsächlich
gesundheitsminister geworden ist schon
kann all diese können all diese frauen
und männer am kommenden mittwoch im
bundestag vereidigt werden und ich muss
eine kleine korrektur nachschieben wo
zumindest soll ich da etwas ungenau
vorher in dem ersten gespräch das wir
geführt haben natürlich gehört auch der
kanzleramtsminister wolfgang schmidt zu
den ministern die vereidigt werden also
nochmal um das ganz klar zu machen wir
haben jetzt hier sieben minister und bzw
ministerin gesehen aus diesem insgesamt
16 köpfigen kabinett davon werden in der
tat acht frauen und acht männer seien
also so wie es olaf scholz im grunde
auch versprochen hat während des
wahlkampfes vergleicht also die
unterschiede die es etwa bei den
fdp-minister rinnen gibt auch hier aus
insofern acht frauen acht männer das war
angestrebt und das haben wir jetzt auch
er hat eines
sehr gerne also herzlichen dank
sozusagen noch mal für das
zusammenfassende votum und ich erinnere
ein gespräch vor ein paar wochen dass
wir hier miteinander an ähnlicher stelle
hatten wo wir noch ein bisschen überlegt
haben wie die neuaufstellung der partei
ist da hatten wir klara geywitz
insbesondere sie hatten sie auf dem
zettel allerdings in anderer funktion
wir über erleben sie jetzt in bauen und
wohnen sie hatten sich sogar zu einer
kleinen wetter durchgerungen wir beide
müssen noch aushandelt schon bei heute
nikolaus ist was wir dafür dann
sozusagen in anschlag bringen aber ganz
herzlichen dank für diese eindrücke
heute an diesem tag der auch
überraschung bietet aus dem
willy-brandt-haus und die woche bietet
ja auch durchaus noch einiges mittwoch
der große tag mit der kanzler mal von
olaf scholz dankte es gibt es gibt wenn
es gibt durchaus noch einen ganz
interessanten punkt auf dem wir den wir
nicht vergessen sollten nämlich das ist
die regionale verteilung irgend dieses
dieser kabinettsliste von der spd da war
es in der vergangenheit ja immer
traditionell so dass möglichst alle
landesverbände daran beteiligt sein
sollten und auch beteiligt wurden das
ist hier in diesem fall überhaupt nicht
mehr der fall wenn man sich das mal
genauer anguckt zwei kommen aus
nordrhein westfalen zwei aus hessen
einmal niedersachsen brandenburg und
berlin das heißt landesverbände wie
bayern wie baden württemberg aber auch
schleswig holstein oder das saarland
sind in diesem kabinett nicht vertreten
man hat hier ganz offensichtlich auch in
intensiven gesprächen dass im vorfeld
aus dem rheinland pfalz ob ich auf
keinen fall vergessen ein wichtiger und
auch sehr erfolgreicher spd
landesverband nicht vertreten in diesem
kabinett zumindest nicht in der ersten
reihe also hier hat sich einiges getan
und das ganze möglicherweise auch einer
der gründe warum es etwas länger
gedauert hat bei der spd mit der
bekanntgabe dieser minister da hat es
mit sicherheit im vorfeld auch mit den
landesverbänden mit den
landesvorsitzenden intensive gespräche
gegeben und das wie gesagt ein durchaus
bemerkenswertes ergebnis dass olaf
scholz in diesem fall und auch die spd
parteispitze nicht nach regionalproporz
gegangen ist sondern nachdem wie sie
oder diejenigen die sie für die
wichtigen und richtigen an ihren
jeweiligen plätzen halten in der tat in
der aufzählung sie drin hatten bei den
landesverbänden de leer ausgegangen sind
sind sie zumindest zwei im nächsten jahr
landtagswahlen vor den augen haben
nämlich saarland und schleswig holstein
wird spannend sein wie sozusagen die
interne debatten lage dann weitergeht
aber 100 tage sind erstmal für jeden
gesetzt und auch darauf hat olaf scholz
geachtet auf die ordentliche
parlamentarische regel dass wir noch
nicht in die sacharbeit einsteigen bevor
nicht alle vereidigt und ihre
ernennungsurkunde haben danke er hat für
diese einschätzung und diese
hintergründe aus dem willy-brandt-haus
wir sind die woche über weiterhin mit
ihm gespräch danke ihnen für den moment
dass sie
meine damen und herren und tatsächlich
haben wir ein bisschen weiter gucken was
dieses kabinett was diese besetzung uns
jetzt anbieten freut mich dass weiterhin
bei uns ist professor volker kunde der
das hier mit uns verfolgt das ist eine
durchaus liste mit
bekannten und mit überraschungen und
wenn wir bei denen sagen wir mal
gesetzten dingen anfangen dann war es
relativ klar dass wir hubertus heil
wieder sehen würden keine überraschung
für uns und auch jemand der genau
eingelöst hat was was alle von ihm
erwartet hatten nicht wahr ja ich stimme
ihnen in der einschätzung völlig zu dass
es eine sichere bank für olaf scholz das
ist ja für ihn auch wichtig so hätte ihn
ja auch an moderiert er kann sich auf
ihn verlassen er hat dieses ressort aus
sicht der spd hoch erfolgreich bereits
verantwortete es bestens vernetzt und er
ist sozusagen auch was die strömungen
angeht das ist vielleicht noch ein
aspekt den wir jetzt in anknüpfung an
der schärfe auch noch in den blick
nehmen können in der regionalproporz ist
das eine wichtige und das andere ist
natürlich die strömungen in der spd auch
wenn sie in den letzten wochen monaten
erstaunlich im hintergrund waren ist es
natürlich immer noch der fall kann er
sich verlassen das ist niedersachsen der
weiß wie es geht und das verbindet sich
sicherlich auch mit einem namen wie
christine lambrecht sie hatte jetzt
schon ressort verantwortung und wir
dürfen auch nicht vergessen
sie war parlamentarischen
geschäftsführern von 2013 bis 17 das
heißt sie sind das parlamentarische
geschäftsführer einer fraktion sind
generalisten die die wissen auch wie die
politik und wenn ich da einfügen darf
ist sozusagen das amt der
verteidigungsministerin in europa zwar
eine durchaus erprobte geschichte wenn
wir nach frankreich schauen aber auch
nach skandinavien aber für deutschland
ist das durchaus immer noch ein recht
singulärer posten werden glaube ich
bisher eine besetzung im
verteidigungsministerium schon sehr
lange her von der cdu es ist in der tat
also was das ressort angeht und die die
zuordnung von frau lamprecht sicherlich
eine überraschung man hätte das wäre
nicht das erste ressort was man mit ihr
verbunden hätte und was man lesen konnte
in den letzten tagen und wochen so ein
stück weit auch gestreut war sicherlich
dass sie das innen ressort aus dem
justiz ressort wechselt ins ohr auch
reizvoll gefunden hätte aber da kommt
sicherlich auch sozusagen der
regionalproporz und da sind wir gleich
bei hessen und neuen innenminister und
das ist glaube ich die ganz große
überraschung
am heutigen montag bei vollem recht muss
man schauen sie ist generalisten damit
wollte ich einfach sagen sie wird sich
ihnen diese schwierige materie dieses
schwierige ressort mit den riesen
herausforderungen und aufgaben vor von
der leyen hatte ja wirklich auch zu
kämpfen das war ja nun weibliche
vorgängerin also insofern wird man da
ihr sicherlich manches auch zutrauen
weil sie eben weiß wie politik
funktioniert aber
den zugriff auf das innenministerium das
musste sicherlich ein stück weit wird
man so sagen auch wenn er stolz ist das
anders präsentiert hat hier der
parteilinken denn da ist der hessische
landesverband natürlich klar
positioniert also nicht nur kühn hat als
künftiger generalsekretär sondern müssen
eben die strömungen auch sehen und das
ist sicherlich die hessische spd fraser
ist eben die landesvorsitzende dort sie
ist die idee ist die oppositionsführerin
die
fraktionsvorsitzenden das ist natürlich
ein großer sprung sozusagen er hat diese
ressortverantwortung bisher ist noch
kein ministeramt geleitet und von
landesebene auf die bundesebene und dann
gleich in ein solches schlüssel ressort
wie das innenministerium mit so vielen
staatssekretären zeigt ja einfach auch
wie hier riesig groß wie viele bezüge in
andere ressorts dieses hat das ist eine
große überraschung da wird man gespannt
sein dürfen wie das dann auch
funktioniert mit blick auf die anderen
ressorts und die anderen
koalitionsparteien in der tat eines der
größten ressorts was deutschland zu
bieten hat mit einer enorm verzahnung
auch in alle sicherheitsorgane da das
sind große fußstapfen in denen sie feser
da tritt als amtsnachfolgerin in dem
falle von dem jetzigen csu amtsinhaber
horst seehofer ein bisschen weiter gehen
sozusagen der minister der herzen ist es
auch geworden
doch einfach
wäre eine riesenüberraschung gewesen und
dass sich glaube ich und das war
sicherlich auch einer der entscheidenden
gründe warum er sich so entschieden hat
kaum ein mann hätte kaum verständnis in
der breiten öffentlichkeit gehabt eine
absage an karl lauterbach er ist ja das
gesicht der spd über lange lange zeit
jetzt anderthalb jahre zu diesem thema
normalerweise würde man ja sagen das
können wir bei den anderen kabinetts
zuschnitten jetzt auch sehen man muss
nicht fachfrau fachmann fahren für das
ressort was man künftig verantwortet
hier war das ein argument dass scholz
angeführt hat lauterbach ist eben hier
experte es mediziner erkennt sich
sozusagen in dieser thematik sehr gut
aus aber er genießt eben in der
bevölkerung eine große popularität und
man traut ihm eben zu weil er jetzt ein
fachmann ist und solange sich schon dazu
äußert dass er das jetzt in den griff
bekommt und das sind natürlich
psychologisch ganz wichtige dinge
gewesen die sicherlich den ausschlag
gegeben haben lassen sie uns noch
konzentriert zwei weitere besetzungen
betrachten beides keine unbekannten für
den stolz wie er überhaupt sozusagen
auch als kriterium auch immer benannt
hat ich möchte auch eine vertrauensbasis
zu der person haben die ich sozusagen
für dieses abend und für dieses ressort
für werth befinde das einmal klara
geywitz mit der er zusammen angetreten
ist für das amt des parteivorsitzenden
schon eine weile her hat damals nicht
geklappt aber dann hatte sie weiterhin
auf dem zettel sie ist mittlerweile dann
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende
geworden und svenja schulze die in einem
nicht so einfach im ressort bisher auch
sich wehren konnte und jetzt mit
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung nicht entwicklungshilfe
sondern entwicklung mag so ein kleiner
fauxpas bei ihm jetzt weiter arbeiten
kann das sind aber beides dann wiederum
sichere bänke für ihn das ist auch ein
bisschen die methode scholz also jetzt
möglichst jetzt niemand der zu sehr aus
dem ruder vielleicht gehen könnte ich
teile ihre einschätzung meiner
beobachtung ist dass sonja schulze
erstens ist sie auch hervorragend
vernetzt in der partei auch hin zu den
jusos ganz wichtig natürlich wir müssen
die strömungen immer im blick haben und
das war schulze natürlich ein wichtiger
faktor und sie hat dass es auch meine
wahrnehmung als umweltministerin die
kanzlerin hat ja auch viel spielraum
gelassen sie hat da auch statur gewonnen
sie konnte wichtige punkte eben auch
setzen weil natürlich das thema umwelt
und energie klima auch eine solche
priorität genossen hat das heißt sie hat
da sozusagen gezeigt dass sie es kann
insofern war sie ein stück weit gesetzt
weise in der partei so verankert ist und
und klara geywitz da teile ich auch ihre
ihre einschätzung sie ist natürlich die
frau aus den ostdeutschen verbänden aber
hier ist es eben auch so dass er hier
weiß er kann sich auf sie verlassen da
scheint die chemie eben auch zustimmen
und von daher gesehen ist sie auch so
habe ich sie wahrgenommen in der
vergangenheit generalisten insofern ist
das natürlich aus sicht der spd ein
wichtiges ressort und kevin kühnert
lässt ja nicht locker sozusagen jetzt
auch im zweifelsfalle den
koalitionsvertrag noch mal infrage
stellen zu wollen mit dem mietpreis
brands und anders als das thema wohnen
wohnungen wohnen ist eben für die spd
auch in ihren verästelungen so wichtig
dass er hier eben diese vertraute und
dann ostdeutschland brandenburg hier
gesetzt hat ein in sich aus sicht der
spd sicherlich stimmiges gesamtpaket ja
es enthält überraschende momente aber es
ist aus sicht von olaf scholz dann mit
dem kanzleramtsminister dem wir
natürlich nicht vergessen der ort sei
aus diesem hintergrund und ein bisschen
ungewöhnlich den mit hinzustellen das
hat man nicht so häufig deswegen ja auch
die sima und deswegen die nachfrage der
kollegin von der süddeutschen zeitung
casting gar nichts zu sagen hey das
stimmt doch jetzt eine parität nicht
mehr hat man nicht so häufig ist aber
sicherlich auch ausdruck der
wertschätzung seitens scholz an wolfgang
schmidt weil jeder auch weiß schon aus
hamburger zeiten ganz früh weil immer an
seiner seite er ist der mann im
hintergrund so hat er sich heute
präsentiert und tatsächlich wird es auf
ihn als kanzleramtsminister dass es ja
eine position das war mal steinmeier
rombach anderen das ist natürlich ein
ganz zentraler koordinator im
hintergrund der diese ressource
natürlich koordinieren muss und das war
unser eingang heute des gesprächs eine
neue konstellation der koalition drei
parteien die nicht unbedingt fdp grüne
immer sozusagen miteinander gut konnten
das ist eine große herausforderung
insofern ist es ein personaltableau das
aus sicht von olaf scholz die
interessenlagen der partei abdeckt aber
vor allen dingen auch berechenbarkeit
für ihn garantiert und das ist für ihn
gerade in dieser anfangsphase auf die es
ankommt die ersten 100 tage die ersten
sechs monate glaube ich genau das
richtige in der tat wenn wir nochmal
später gelegenheit haben sollten zu
reden könnten wir noch mal auf diese
besondere woche schauen aber für den
moment würde ich nicht erst mal bedanken
ganz herzlichen dank für ihre
einschätzung professor volker kronenberg
politikwissenschaftler an der
universität bonn meine damen und herren
das stichwort kanzleramtsminister passt
ganz gut für uns als übergang an dieser
funktion die so wichtig ist um an das
gefüge in gang zu halten hat auch ein
mann gearbeitet der heute so etwas wie
seinen letzten großen auftritt hat in
der bundespolitik 63 jahre alt begonnen
mal als beamter bei der eu kommission
dann viele stationen gemacht ein
saarländer mit dieser